it starts with picking one oh you know
already boom
Oh Alysha fresh-squeezed oj oh how much
Papa you're supposed to take out the
whole thing
like a pumpkin of course yeah I was just
taking out just enough to eat all right
here we go get in there get in it yeah
don't be afraid of the mess that's the
key now cut faces as desired this is
where the artistry comes into play this
is also where band-aids may need to come
into play now dude let's keep super safe
okay
language oh no this is not gonna be good
I'm a BU you sweetie look at those teeth
right Dean has a dentist so you know
what I was winning for a while
but then in the homestretch he took it
to another level yours is so happy oh
let them kiss we made each other
Oh what does it mean Internet
so far so good
fold one of the squares in half
diagonally to form a triangle fold that
triangle in half two more times to
narrow it the paragraph for you on what
hmm
I'm sorry all right how much time do we
have left
what is this web what are you talking
about how did they get to the web
I think they skipped a paragraph okay
I'm just gonna make a web out of this
okay I'm not gonna start David I'm the
person if a kid comes to my door I'll
give them just peppermints and not
actual candies peppermints are candy
they're not fun candy no they're a
bummer yeah but it's like socks for your
birthday you give a kid peppermint at
Halloween what no you guys having to
sketch out so uh there's my spider I'm
gonna give it to Quinta yes thanks dick
I really admire what you did do with it
you made something out of nothing in
that one skinny chick each half and
gently carve out the mouth or the small
knife okay right well that's good stuff
the inside with a tablespoon of
sunflower butter that can't be good
amazingly delicious yeah you realize
that the dynamics of a sunflower I see
that there's a sharpened and a soft that
some ninjas only use sunflower seeds to
kill their opponents so right the
jugular oh my god are you okay whoo
let's do this you know you want it oh
okay it does make a good snack what does
that remind you of have a melon stay
away from that one there we go
now we're talking you know what it's got
a sweetness this is probably loaded with
sugar three grams
not bad oh we're serving it's just tell
me how many grams are in the whole thing
because I'm gonna eat this whole thing
if I were president we would know how
much of have calories were in a case of
everything
want to be on the Kanye ticket in 2020
black Kanye Kanye glass yeah I get a
crazy why are we using his first name
and your last hahaha wet black doesn't
have as good as a ring to it
I've got some legislation I'd like to
push through Congress put how many
calories are the butter for the whole
container cuz that's what I want to eat
Kanye black 2016